hey what is up guys I'm PFC here and
this is USB see all the things part two
so part one was going over the best of
USB type-c accessories to help you
bridge the gap between the old outgoing
full-sized USB a standard and the new
incoming Universal standard USB type-c
now that was more than six months ago
but this part two is talking to you
manufacturers of electronics so a PSA to
electronics companies now is the time to
go ahead and just feel free to USB see
all the things it's 2017 and we're in
this awkward sort of middle phase where
it's not quite a no-brainer to go with
USB type-c and a new device even though
you totally should a lot of electronics
and computers and accessories and things
are coming out that don't use USB type-c
even still because it isn't quite
everywhere yet you might be a little
worried about compatibility with older
customers or people getting confused
about having this new port when they
still have this old port in other places
but I'm telling you that you guys can be
the ones to push forward into this
future to make it less confusing take
Apple for example with their laptops
obviously Apple is one of those
companies who can do this but they
basically just declared and decided that
they wanted USBC to be the future of
connectivity and their devices so with
all the new MacBooks and MacBook Pros
their entire laptop lineup they took
away full-size USB a ports and replace
them all with USB type-c 3.1 there's no
downsides and now there's way less
confusion because you've gone straight
from the old one to the new one the old
port to the new port and now all the
ports on all the Mac books are USB
type-c that's a much easier mental
hurdle to clear of why a new port exists
and the old one doesn't anymore
another example is Samsung with their
smartphones they've wizened up a lot too
they used to have microUSB in some
phones and USB micro-b for the note that
was a weird one but now if you check out
the smartphone lineup boom it's USB see
across the board in fact many
smartphones coming out now are a USB
type-c
and that's a great categorical example
of companies moving forward quickly
because of heavy competition so pretty
much every smartphone you'll see coming
out now
has USB type-c except for the iPhone but
other categories don't necessarily have
the same stiff rigorous competition so
they're not necessarily in that same
race to adopt the most badass features
as quickly as possible take this mouse
for example Logitech MX master literally
one of my favorite mice ever came out in
early 2015 so a couple years ago and
then recently Logitech decided it's time
for a refresh so they came out with the
Logitech MX master 2's nice so a little
bit of a refresh new coating some new
color choices to pick from a newer
longer-lasting battery a higher dpi
sensor but at the front the same micro
USB now in something as simple as a
mouse Logitech probably accurately
thought it's probably doesn't even
matter if you switch to USB type-c or
not there's no crunch for space there's
no need to use a smaller faster port
here and the only thing you actually use
the cable for with this mouse is
charging anyway so who really cares why
spend the extra money on a new chipset
inside just to use the newer fancier USB
type-c but if we're going to move faster
into this world of USB type-c everywhere
then this is the kind of stuff that has
to get switched to USB type-c even if it
doesn't seem like it's gonna matter it
actually does in the end maybe the best
way to do it if you're concerned about
laggers are concerned about confusion or
compatibility is to do what Samsung did
with their portable SSD this is the
samsung t1 SSD you know the TLD guys
originally recommended it to me and it's
just been awesome to rip around files
and move stuff between machines
it's a terabyte right here in the palm
of my hand but it's split microUSB but
that's of course an older product so you
fast forward to 2017 you get the newer
versions of these guys the t3 and the t5
and the t5 is of course straight to USB
type-c but if you look in the package
the t5 comes with two cables one is a
USB type-c 2 USB type-c cable for the
future we're looking forward to but the
other is a USB type-c to full size USB a
cable that way anyone can use it you
have the cable option there but it
clearly still favors moving forward to
USB type-c now of course USB 3.1 and the
new connector really do matter and
like a portable SSD where speed matters
but this would be even more awesome to
see everyday in things like the Logitech
mouse with portable battery packs with
cameras with keyboards with speakers
with whatever accessories are being
refreshed or coming out in 2017 and 2018
that would be really great to see so
that's just my brief PSA shoutout to the
manufacturers who are already putting
USBC in their devices even though no one
told you you had to and looking forward
to those who aren't catching up for 2017
and 2018 until then there's been mkbhd
thank you for watching taht you guys the
next one pace
[Music]